marine calme est militante écologiste et
présidente de l'association one day
légal
bonjour marine qu'elle mais merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vient
de voir
lucas léger du côté d'amiens et des
chasseurs parler à son micro tout à
l'heure on a eu bruno david également en
invités qui étaient en skype comme vous
ces rassemblements de chasseurs
aujourd'hui sont l'occasion selon lui
d'appeler les militants écologistes à
prendre connaissance des réalités de la
vie dans les compagnes qu'est ce que
vous lui répondez
la réalité de la vie dans les campagnes
c'est que les oiseaux les populations
d'oiseaux diminue drastiquement on parle
d'une perte de biodiversité de 30 % en
30 ans donc plutôt que de parler
justement de prendre conscience de la
réalité dans la campagne peut-être qu'il
faut tout simplement reconnaître les
chiffres donnés par les scientifiques
rappelait d'ailleurs la semaine dernière
au congrès mondial pour la biodiversité
auquel emmanuel mavs qu'on était
pourtant
présent et a donné encore une fois à
entendre de grands engagements pour la
biodiversité au niveau de la france mais
on voit bien que dans les faits
justement nous n'écoutons pas la science
nous n'écoutons pas les règles de
l'union européenne et ça c'est très
inquiétant parce que les pratiques de
chasse traditionnelle puisqu'on parle là
j'entendais votre reportage de préserver
les pratiques de chasse traditionnelle
qui sont en fait des pratiques
minoritaires parmi les pratiques de chat
c'est à dire que contrairement aux
pratiques de tir et l'achat salade lui
la chasse au filet et la chasse à la
cage sont des pratiques minoritaires et
pourquoi elles sont interdites parce
qu'elle piège de manière tout à fait
indistincte dit les espèces d oiseaux et
donc ça évidemment c'était vous un
chasseur dans le reportage qui
expliquait que
il y avait des catégories des espèces
d'oiseaux qui était ciblé et qu'il
fallait souvent aller vers la cage pour
justement libérer les autres oiseaux
donc il n'ya pas une volonté également
chez eux quand même de vouloir cibler
les
espèces
et c'est technique de chasse sont
interdites par l'union européenne parce
que justement on ne peut pas attendre du
bon vouloir d'un chasseur d'aller
ensuite libéré les oiseaux il ya des
raisons tout à fait technique pour ça et
ça s'entend aujourd'hui si d'autres
techniques de chasse son mythe mise en
oeuvre qui sont des techniques plus
sélectives dans ce cas là la france
pourra tout à fait prendre des arrêtés
pour les autoriser mais aujourd'hui
celles qui ont été interdites alors et
interpellent ont été interdits
d'ailleurs cet été par le conseil d'état
et donc aujourd'hui ce qui est
inquiétant c'est de voir que ces
pratiques pourraient être ré autorisé on
le sait la lp o a révélé il ya quelques
jours que des projets d'arrêtés
ministériels étaient en cours de
préparation pour ré autoriser certaines
pratiques alors même que le conseil
d'état donc la plus haute juridiction
administrative française les a
interdites et donc on se pose la
question du pur clientélisme de ce
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron face à
la pression de certains chasseurs et
encore une fois pour des pratiques
traditionnelles qui ne sont pas
représentatives en plus de l'ensemble
des produits comme ge annoncé des enjeux
électoralistes
complètement là on est vraiment dans un
clientélisme c'est à dire que on a d'un
côté ces gens qui font monter la
pression soit disant pour représenter
les chasses traditionnelles mais de
l'autre côté on a les scientifiques on a
le gouvernement qui prend des
engagements en matière de biodiversité
et tout ça explose en l'air à la moindre
pression politique alors qu'aujourd'hui
on le sait il ya beaucoup plus de
personnes en france qui demandent
justement l'arrêt de ce genre de
pratique la pratique de la chasse à la
glu ça choque énormément de gens
aujourd'hui on voudrait tourner la page
de ce genre de pratiques alors il faut
peut être penser justement à trouver de
nouvelles famines quand on est chez les
chasseurs ça choque les urbains et pas
forcément les personnes rural l'un des
arguments des chasseurs andins la
tradition c'est également que la chasse
ça fait partie de la chaîne alimentaire
une forme de gestion naturels de la
faune là aussi qu'est ce que vous
répondez
à ceux qui tiennent ce genre de discours
alors personnellement je travaille des
peuples autochtones en guyane française
e on peut parler de chasse alimentaire
parce que le prochain supermarché il a
trois jours de pirogue là excusez moi
mais ça vraiment rien à voir en plus il
faut bien voir que la sociologie des
chasseurs en france sont majoritairement
des professions des cadres et des
libéraux et en plus de ça une grande
partie d'entre eux sont des urbains donc
franchement là on est plutôt en fait
dans un espèce de complaisance on essaie
d'entretenir un mythe aujourd'hui du bon
chasseur la vérité c'est qu'il ya des
pratiques de chasse aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne sont pas sélectifs qu'on peut même
pas comparer à de la chasse puisque en
fait c'est juste un loisir chassé à la
glu ou tendre des filets aujourd'hui
malheureusement il ya vraiment une
remise en question à avoir de ces
pratiques de chasse de la manière dont
on pratique c'est cette activité sur le
territoire parce qu'on met en danger la
biodiversité la protection de nos
écosystèmes et ça c'est intolérable
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
marine calme et je rappelle que vous
êtes militante écologiste et présidente
de l'association wild légal